Jujutsu Kaizen season 2 is finally here
and the hype Is Real at the end of the
last season everyone was impressed by
how the first years Yuji megumi and
nobara managed to defeat Three Special
great curses on their own but if you
thought that was an epic development
just wait for what season 2 has in store
Gojo's crazy backstory the Dark Truth
About ghetto megumi's badass father and
the absolutely game-changing Shibuya
incident a bunch of mysteries from
season one are about to be revealed and
even bigger Mysteries are about to be
introduced the Shibuya incident changes
everything in the world of Jujutsu
Kaizen forever and we are about to
witness all of it together in anime form
are you as excited as I am let me know
down in the comments subscribe right now
to anime uproar for all the latest
Jujutsu Kaizen season 2 updates and
check out our jjk video playlist Link in
the pinned comment